reasontv presents citizens against
government waste spore kurz of the month
senators Tom Carper and George Voinovich
for every gallon of gasoline bought in
the United States 18.4 cents goes to the
federal government revenue from the
federal gasoline tax goes to the Highway
Trust Fund intended for infrastructure
repair but passed highway bills have
spent that money on museums horse trails
graffiti removal music Center's even a
hovercraft in Toledo Ohio because
hovercrafts are way cooler than
repairing bridges of course taxpayers
just funded an 862 billion dollar
stimulus package that was also supposed
to be aimed at infrastructure repair
only to see that money diverted to
giving cocaine to monkeys and reducing
hot flashes through yoga with that money
gone and highway still in this repair
these two recently proposed hiking the
federal gasoline tax on more than one
hundred thirty five percent because that
monkey is really jonesing for some more
infrastructure for more information
about poker of the month and other
government waste issues visit CA GW org
you